I think you know people like you who've
got a big heart and a big brain and a
good message and good values we need you
to have more attention bigger platforms
the people who are the [ __ ] the
people who are really I mean there are
people in this world who are really just
out for themselves or who really just
don't care or who actually just mean
those people never shrink from the
opportunity to grab the microphone and
so therefore I think it's important for
other people to have an equal and fair
shot well for me I'm just all about
trying to get the job done
accomplish the goal I mean for us it's
like let's eradicate poverty let's put
money into people's hands let's make it
so that people have the opportunity to
be time starved and not just starving
you know when you see those food lines
now we have food lines in America people
in their cars because of the the virus
and the economic crash people are in in
their cars for two hours three hours
trying to drive up to food pantries and
food banks to get a little bit of food
that's not gonna work
and you have ideas that can it can
eliminate all that and you know and so I
do think is linked people can also tell
when you stop being mission first and
you start being me first then the air
comes out of the balloon pretty quickly
anyway and so you know I would just tell
any of your critics or whatever hey just
you know just watch me keep me honest
and see how it works out yeah to me we
just need to get the job done and
whatever tools come my way to get the
job done like I'm all for yeah like if
someone who's been bashing me at a
particular point in time then like comes
around later I'm just like cool let's do
it you know when I left the Obama White
House under fire you know had been such
a radical firebrand in my 20s and 30s I
was considered a left-wing radical in
the bay area now you have to work hard
to distinguish yourself in the Bay Area
as a left winger but I did it and and
then after my son was born and I started
you know trying to figure out more
constructive ways to to be a part of the
the local political community I wind up
doing this green jobs core in Oakland
getting kids off the street corners and
trained to put up solar panels Nancy
Pelosi finds out about it I went up
going to DC to talk about the program to
all of her people we get george w bush
to sign a bill called the green Jobs Act
of 2007 which replicated my program
across the country through the
Department of Labor next year I wrote a
book about of the book became a
best-seller suddenly you know I'm in the
Obama White House and you know working
on with an eighty billion dollar budget
working with Joe Biden and you know a
bunch of other people Valerie Jarrett
trying to get you know the green part of
the stimulus package to work and
instantly the right wing says wait a
minute this guy's in the White House is
like you know protester this guy who's
like against the police and all this
sort of stuff you know the instant
firestorm in those days you couldn't be
controversial and stay in the White
House so I resigned they didn't ask me
to resign I offered to resign I resigned
and and and I took a lot of heat from
conservatives here we are ten years
later or you know they're about some of
those same people who come after me so
hard I work with all the time